[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
ma
grandissimo matteo macchioni ma non è
finita qui insieme a lui perché abbiamo
alcune domande da farti matteo
approfondire del tempo a nostra
disposizione
in una veste non scontata quella appunto
dell'intervistato che solito ti ti
presento a cantare esibirti quindi mi
toglierò anche qualche curiosità matt è
legata anche al tema di questo telex
modena che appunto è vision of super ma
mi sono un po documentata anche in
quello che è un tuo mondo che è molto
bello ma molto particolare ma è vero che
l'opera lirica e visione oltre che
ascolto che cosa si intende
assolutamente sì è verissimo
l'opera lirica è una forma d'arte
straordinaria e nel suo luogo d'elezione
dove si pratica per il pubblico cioè il
teatro proprio adesso ci troviamo sul
palco di un teatro d'opera all'italiana
e
a teatro la musica si riproduce
attraverso l'orchestra dal vivo ma anche
si vede l'azione scenica quindi la
componente visiva è un connubio
importantissimo insieme alla componente
uditiva lasciami dire una cosa molto
importante per me la musica è stata
un'esigenza da subito fin da bambino con
il ritmo ma l'amore verso questa forma
d'arte l'opera lirica è nata in me
quando ho avuto la possibilità di
entrare in un teatro d'opera a vedere
uno spettacolo
non a caso ho usato il verbo vedere in
teatro si va a vedere lo spettacolo
questa cosa che mi è successa da bambino
mi è stata data questa possibilità ha
creato una sorta di anima eterea che si
è impadronita di me e mi ha guidato in
tutti gli anni futuri in quello che poi
è stato il mio percorso artistico quindi
decisamente sì l'opera si sente e si
vede
vediamo e sentiamo soprattutto quella
che la tua grande passione oltre che il
tuo lavoro però ti chiedo che cosa
rappresenta cosa ha rappresentato per te
portare il belcanto nel mondo adesso ci
siamo tutti fermati però speriamo che si
possa ripartire definitivamente beh
essere un giovane cantante lirico
italiano e avere la possibilità
l'onore e il piacere di portare il bel
canto italiano il nostro retaggio
culturale fuori dai confini nazionali
non è solo per me un lavoro una
professione un mestiere è soprattutto
una missione artistica perché l'emozione
che si prova quando fuori dai confini
nazionali ti capita di stare sul palco
con artisti di diverse nazionalità che
cantano tutti in italiano e tu hai la
responsabilità ulteriore di essere nato
in italia ad avere studiato in italia di
essersi formato in italia questo ti crea
una responsabilità incredibile e
soprattutto
un compito una missione perché molti non
lo sanno ma l'opera lirica italiana fa
parlare italiano nel mondo per quanto mi
riguarda apro una parentesi e la chiudo
l'opera lirica dovrebbe essere
considerata patrimonio dell unesco
patrimonio dell'umanità e avere questo
riconoscimento speriamo che lo abbia in
futuro è molto molto importante questo
ti dà la doppia responsabilità perché
essendo italiano non ti puoi sbagliare
ma attenzione perché non solo italiano
ma anche modenese tu vieni dalla città
del bel canto viene dalla città di
luciano pavarotti una grande
responsabilità si essere nato a una
decina di chilometri più o meno da da
dove è nato big luciano è una grande
responsabilità
ma
per me essere nato nella provincia di
modena non ha rappresentato dei vantaggi
soprattutto da ragazzino vale come per
tanti altri la locuzione latina nemo
profeta in patria soprattutto quando hai
un esempio di così elevata altezza
artistica cosa mi piace di luciano
pavarotti cosa mi ha ispirato la purezza
la brillantezza il carattere chiaro e
limpido della sua voce non a caso è
stato detto da molti che dio baciò le
corde vocali di luciano pavarotti è una
cosa che mi ha molto stupito
perché ha ispirato mema tante
generazioni di cantanti lirici è il modo
con cui lui si è approcciato a
quest'arte molti non lo sanno ma lui era
figlio di un fornaio il papa era fornaio
e cantava nella corale rossini di modena
quindi per empatia è arrivato a luciano
pavarotti quello che è
l'incipit la cosiddetta scintilla della
curiosità e ha ispirato anche a me
questa cosa quindi vedere questa voce
brillante sentire questa voce
straordinaria questo personaggio al di
là del glamour e dalla popolarità io
parlo proprio del gesto vocale ha
ispirato ma come tante generazioni di
cantanti lirici e questo è un ambito
molto importante per me una visione su
per una visione del futuro che dobbiamo
avere
dobbiamo impegnarci tantissimo nella
formazione nell'alfa betis d'azione
artistica dei giovani perché se io sono
potuto andare in teatro da da ragazzino
quando frequentavo la scuola primaria e
se ho potuto sentire una voce come
luciano pavarotti molti delle
generazioni di ora non hanno questa
possibilità
in italia manca una formazione capillare
e costante sull'alfabetizzazione
musicale perché se noi insegniamo
più che insegniamo facciamo conoscere
l'arte e la bellezza a dieci bambini
forse non avremmo dieci musicisti e
dieci cantanti ma sicuramente avremmo
dieci persone con le orecchie istruite
colte e pronte anche ad apprezzare il
bello e questo è molto importante per il
nostro futuro questa è la cosa più
importante per me è una visione del
futuro che dobbiamo avere una vision of
super guarda un bellissimo messaggio
anche legato proprio la formazione e
speriamo che anche questo messaggio
venga accolto e che si possa creare un
percorso di formazione ad hoc come
dicevamo proprio nella terra per
antonomasia del bel canto quindi andiamo
al lupo perché il vostro stato uno dei
settori più colpiti dalla pandemia però
insomma facciamo un grande applauso a
matteo macchioni però che ci aveva
donato anche qualche minuto di bella
musica
grazie ma grazie a tutti